what's up everybody today we have a very
special guest mr. Daniel Scott he is a
certified Adobe instructor and today
he's going to share his top five tips
for Photoshop so some of the tools that
Daniel is sharing our huge time savers I
thought I worked efficiently until I saw
this man work and seeing him use the
tools the way that he does blew my mind
so hopefully you guys get a lot of value
out of this video you get to see the way
that Daniel works and how he's using the
latest updates in Photoshop to save you
a lot of time and work more effectively
in Photoshop if you're interested in
following along the tutorials that
Daniel has shared with us check out the
links in the description below and you
can download the sample files so that
you could follow along in these
tutorials alright with that let's get
into it
hi there in this video I'm gonna cover
my top 5 Photoshop features now this
video is for designers who have the
latest version of the software but never
get the time to go through and check out
all the upgrades if you want to follow
along with this video exactly there are
exercise files you can download there'll
be our free link in the description also
if you want to go further with Photoshop
you might want to check out my Photoshop
essentials and Advanced Course there'll
be a link for that in the description
too alright let's get going all right
our first top feature is something
called content aware scale
it's amazing feature where we just need
to magic more background ready magic
just gets bigger but if you're like hey
I already know that one or hey look at
your tree scan you're squished don't
worry I'm gonna show you how to protect
different areas all right first up let's
go to file let's go to open and find
your exercise files okay and we're gonna
open up this one called content-aware
one click open alright depending on how
your Photoshop looks I'm gonna get a
window workspace I'm gonna leave it on
essentials and click reset essentials
just so hopefully mine looks a little
bit more like you alright so what we
need to do is we need the format for
this photograph to be a little wider
okay so it's a common problem now okay
this kind of photograph size okay the
ratio the height versus the width never
seems to work especially in kind of like
the digital world so I'm gonna grab the
crop tool okay over the side here and
then click hold and drag this right hand
side just to give myself a chunk more
you need a lot longer okay at least a
lot wider then click return on my
keyboard or enter on the keyboard next
thing I want to do is go back to our
move tool which is the first tool go up
to edit we're gonna use content aware
scale okay this one here perfect I've
got this layer selected if yours is not
working okay just make sure your layer 0
is selected over here if you're using an
older version of Photoshop you might
have to name it it might be called
background just double click the word
background and give it a name we're
gonna use edit scale and all I need to
do is drag it to the right so there's a
little handle here and if you're using
the new version of Photoshop you're
probably like me and are hating the new
adjustment okay you need to hold down
shift otherwise it's gonna scale it
proportionately so what we need to do is
this little right handle here hold down
shift click hold and start dragging your
mouse all the time holding shift and
magically the background gets bigger yep
tree gets bigger grass gets bigger and
look at it look at the
the seat magic and the reason I picked
this one is that I wanted to show you
what happens when it goes wrong you're
like the trade and the trees not working
and if you use if you've never used
content aware scale holy moley that is
amazing okay just make small background
if you have used it and you're like yeah
look it doesn't work for everything I'm
gonna show you a little trick to make it
a little bit better so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna hit the scape to get
rid of it that's the I didn't mean it
we're going back to start again what we
can do is we can do a really rough
selection you can use any selection tool
I'm going to use this third tool down
and we use the lasso okay a selection
tool and we I just got to kind of like
acknowledge where the problems were
before so I'm gonna kind of just go
around the tree trunk that's where the
most of the problems where the base was
okay you can be really rough with this
it's pretty cool okay so my selection is
horrible and big but it should work so
what do we do now we need to go to
select and save that selection give it a
name tree okay you can give it any sort
of name click OK then go to select
deselect okay and you're like does that
done nothing yet so what we do is we go
back into our edit and go to content
aware scale but before we start
stretching it watch this we say protect
the tree please game awesome click on
that hold down the shift key grab the
right hand one click hold drag drag drag
and look at the tree he's been left
alone okay the background is getting
stretched and there's only so far you
can go we might be going a little too
far this one but there's a couple little
things that might protect again but
pretty amazing huh if you've ever had to
like even just doing like I hit return
on my keyboard to kind of confirm that
but even if you've done like double page
spread you know you get the photograph
and it's not quite right
wide enough to cover those that magazine
spread you can just drag it out a little
bit protect the areas that get wrecked
here you can drag it up you can drag it
right it's super handy especially when
you tie it together with that sweet
feature of protecting different areas
all right before we move on to the next
one I want to go to our libraries panel
because it's create a new library so
click on this little drop down we're
gonna come right down the bottom and
create new library and this one
to be called future with Annie Academy
Academy and I put everything in here for
the risk that's course we're gonna try
and tie it all together I'm gonna try
anyway
now over here I've got this layer
selected I can click this little plus
and say add the graphic okay or I can
just use my move tool and click hold and
drag it into the library if you are not
using the library it's not part of way
like main features it's just part of
trying to like you interested in
libraries as part of this course it's
like a background treat how about two of
them anyone give me a quick name it's
called layer zero double click it let's
call this one Park one all right on to
super amazing feature number two all
right feature number two is
content-aware fill similar to scale and
like I did in the last example I'll show
you the easy way we make this seat
disappear hey presto
then I'll show you this way which we all
run into where hey presto doesn't work
and you end up with this Thank You
Photoshop but don't worry I'm gonna show
you a cool new feature where we can do
this way better not perfect but it's
pretty good when you have to remove
those large objects from an image
instead of those real easy ones like the
first champ all right let's jump in work
out how to do it
all right so content-aware fill and we
just need to make a selection you can
use anything lasso tools I'm gonna use
the polygonal polygonal what if you call
that one okay you can use the magic wand
tool if you like and you could be very
vague with this tool we love it because
you don't have to be an expert to get it
going I'm just clicking once once once
around trying to get rid of the chair
okay do a little bit of a selection okay
so I've got a very average selection if
we just go to edit and we go to fill and
we make sure it says contents make sure
it's set to content-aware and we click
OK and it's magic it's gone let's go to
select deselect a little bit of
repetitive sin there but I promise you
if you did a few different times you'll
get kind of like different parts but you
can imagine instead of using something
like the clone tool stamp or trying I
kind of like patch it together by
copying and pasting way easier continue
we're fill as a maze
now if you're like hey I already done
there before but like the other tool we
look to move a content aware scale there
are sometimes problems and that's what I
want to give you in this video is not
just the easy solution but the hard ones
let's look at one of those hard ones
let's go to file it's gonna open we're
gonna do the same thing but we're gonna
use content or where to I'll show you
one of the problems so this one here if
I go clickety click click same as before
and then try and get rid of this cheer
and we know if we go edit fill let me go
contents content away and we go do it
magic now we realize done turn like
grass over here is pretty good but like
it's got the tree and not quite working
so we're gonna undo so the trick is now
you need to use the CC 2019 or above
version K 20 will come out soon and but
you need to be using the latest version
because this is new okay content aware
fill okay this wasn't there before I was
kind of all tied up in there so content
aware fills pretty good it gives you
this pretty nice workspace so here on my
left I'm gonna zoom out a little bit
kind of mesh this one's over here let's
type in 47 what we're saying is the
green stuff is where it's looking to
replace so it's going ok I'm gonna grab
a bit of the tree a bit of the sky but
at the grass and try and smoosh it all
together what you can do is up here you
can say I'd like to - I'm gonna put my
brush size up real big 500 ok and say
actually I don't want any of the tree
please and what you'll notice is
dynamically it's updating over here it's
gone ok I'm gonna use that but I'm gonna
use a list but you liked holidays let's
just go through and just paint out all
the bit you don't want Photoshop to be
like sampling from can you slowly work
your way out and I'd say pretty good
like I'm showing it like it's not
absolutely perfect ok but we all know
that it's never gonna be like 100% there
but you can see how much bit it was
continuous fill and how much better it
would be then kind of just
Do It Yourself with maybe that stamp
tool the clone stamp or the healing
brush they're all two automatic
whereas this we can be very specific and
say I want all this but maybe not this
but okay
maybe not this bird and maybe not this
back bear here and you can kind of
really focus it down now the other
things you can do with us is over here
on the right hand side okay so don't
worry this top part it says fill
settings here so you've got color
adaption okay this is the main one here
by default okay you can play around with
all four of these don't worry too much
about what color redemption is think of
it as option one two three and four and
we'll change the look so default let's
look at none okay and it's gonna try and
it'll just look a whole lot different
let's try hi and just try and find one
that you find you feel works the best
again it's never gonna be a hundred
percent perfect I guess I want to be
realistic about it but I like that one
don't like default okay just gives you
some extra options alright there's a
little bit of work to do other things
you can do is scales quite use rotation
would be useful if you liked working
with stuff that had like maybe geometric
patterns in it I I never find that
useful but play around with it it's not
gonna work good in this case okay it
rotates it rather than kind of keeping
it straight scaled quite useful looks at
perspective and goes alright that's
quite far so it scales it up to get
closer I find scale can be a real big
game-changer and once you've done scale
go through the color reduction again and
kind of work out alright working closer
or further away to something that looks
pretty good
let's pick okay let's get rid of this
section okay select deselect and you'll
see here look it's on its own nice
little layer now edit to my library as
well what I'd like to do is join these
two so I've grabbed the top one hold
down shift grab the second one right
click it I'm gonna convert to smart
object so it's one nice little group
rather than moving it around as two
pieces
okay I'm gonna give it a name I was
gonna call Park too and I'm gonna click
hold drag the thumbnail into here I've
got my two options start my friends
that's content-aware fill great new tool
Photoshop thank you very much let's get
on to the next feature alright feature
number three it's called select subject
but with the bonus edition of selected
masks it's amazing for making selections
around people with one click
really easy go I promise you that was
just one click of my mouse made a pretty
amazing selection it gets better when we
start looking at bugs with his arrow
focus furry little ears we use select
subject with the addition of selected
masks to do this he's still a
funny-looking pug but you can see how
look at the fur coming through in the
background super quick super easy be the
latest version of Photoshop this is
hopefully gonna save you years off your
masking life alright little bonus for
when we're getting started to open up
more than one document in Photoshop and
select them all so click on the first
one hold shift grab the last one drag
them and on a Mac you can just drag them
into the icon that is in your taskbar
and whether the programs open or not and
it will open everything up for you
another way that I do it and this is a
bit more PC friendly ish is if the
programs open
you grab all three of them hold down
your command tab key on a PC okay
sorry on a Mac and you can just drag it
into the Photoshop icon okay let go and
they'll open up on a PC it's control tab
brings up that same thing so I'm in my
finder I grab it
come on tab on a Mac ctrl tab on a PC
and just drag it into whichever program
you want to open up in alright let's
start with number one okay select
subject 1 are you really for masking
amazingness there's a pretty easy one
okay because it's got a nice clear
background already so let's look at the
easy way select it's got a subject and
magically it's just gonna pick out the
person look at that go down here we're
gonna go our background layer we're
gonna add a layer mask and not perfect
around here we're gonna do a little bit
of extras in a second but pretty easy
quick way to get started its look good
this one here a lot more complicated
you'd be here for a very long time you
the magic one tool or the quick
selection tool or any sort of tool
you're like but there's two things in
here you're like yes somehow this tool
is magic and goes select subject it
doesn't have to be a person or a dog it
can be a group of people a group of dogs
it can be an object say you're a product
photographer it will work for any kind
of like unique thing there's some magic
calculations with focuses other magic
that I don't really understand but you
can see the selection it's pretty
amazing to get started at least okay
I've added my layer mask and although
the hair needs a bit of work it's not a
pretty good like to click our mask this
is one of those things where I haven't
just picked and like subjects that work
perfectly with it I just picked random
ones because we're gonna do this dog
theme later on but it does work that
well all the time I mean don't worry the
he gets better as well let's do it for
this subject 3 ok this fella I love pugs
I don't own a pug or at least I don't
live cohabit with a pug and but let's do
it select let's go to subject and
magically watch it knows what a pug is
you can see there it's got the focused
bits but not the focus bits
it's pretty amazing let's go get started
so you're like that's pretty good but
let's zoom in and you're like I don't
zoom in because look at the edges it's
pretty good though right
that's pretty amazing regardless but
there's bits we need to fix up let's
look at fixing up those edges so select
subject gets you this far or at least
gives you this kind of matching ends
then you can do whatever you want with
it and I'll show you what I think the
next kind of BIST magic trick is to fix
the edges up so first of all give it a
layer mask okay to get started then with
that layer mask selected k-member you
can have the image selected or the layer
mask ok have that selected so doesn't
really matter how you get here you could
use select subject you could do color
range is really cool focus here is
really cool there's lots of different
ways of doing selections even the good
old magic wand at least had the layer
mask applied and then have it selected
here and use select and MA
it's only a properties handled penalty
them okay so you get into here now what
you'll use to be a little different okay
so up the top here where it says view I
like to see mine on black okay and I
like to see that it up to 100% this is
seeing it at its worst right zoom out a
little bit now like the content aware
fill this is like its own like little
world you can see that toolbars kind of
gone everything's looking a little
different so when you're finished you
can either hit cancel or okay get out of
here so what do you need to do there's
some general kind of all over settings
you can play around with okay we'll do
that because sometimes like this guys
fur is pretty much the same all the way
around where I say on some of our
earlier stuff okay where there's like
the woman's here and the dog's fur you
might have to do some of these tools
over the side here but we'll look at
both so over here edges section this
radius here is quite helpful okay and
it's just kind of a matter of like
dragging it up and you'll see the edges
change little bit it's it's go real high
to see what it does you can see they're
kind of started eating back into the
just kind of expands the edge you can
get some really good effects with radius
okay and it works all the way around
let's keep it reasonably low because I
want to show you some other features
smooth can work depend on how good
quality images is medium quality ugh so
it's just can you see it smoothed it out
it's not really working for our here so
we're gonna keep this smooth down fear
that I don't really like or use either
with contrast but play around with them
you might find them great for your
particular and subject matter you might
not be dealing with bugs and people ok
ship deer just really handy it just kind
of like sucks it in watch or pushes it
out okay and do me you pull it in a
little bit to get rid of any sort of
ghosting but before you do that okay
leave shift edge alone okay it should be
the last one because this thing here is
magic decontaminate colors does this
magic potion where it just kind of grabs
whatever background color and kind of
pulls it out of your image so I find
that's probably better than the shift
edge and it's working okay in this pug
image but I've had like just the magic
breakthrough moments okay where I just
click on this little button before I do
anything and adjustment
everything all right so these are really
good kind of like average like not
average general things to do okay if all
of the edges around this edge are the
same like this dog here okay is you can
use these kind of generic ones but if
you've got like little particular things
that are wrong you start using these
tools and this first are the second one
down here this is probably the best one
the refine edge brush tool so click on
this one in terms of the size I'm using
a hundred here okay because it kind of
overlaps it's probably a little bit big
okay what I wanted to do is I want it to
be a just so kind of overlaps a little
bit the background a little bit of the
edge where I want this kind of like fur
transition to happen
ooh little shortcut while we're here
hold down control + option on a Mac and
hold those two keys down okay and click
and hold your mouse key and drag to the
right or the left it does the size okay
rather than having to do it up here okay
and then up and the down is fuzziness
okay or hardness so up is fully fully
fuzzy and dragging it down as hardness
at 100 you can lift and right up and
down on a PC to do the same thing you
hold down the Alt key
okay just that and then you use your
right mouse button click and hold that
down and do the same left and right up
and down okay it's a weird thing nobody
uses the right mouse key but paint this
tool does it's really handy picking your
brush size rather than kind of trying to
count it and kind of move you know he's
gonna do it and then move it down do it
go down I'm this at zero making sure
mines on plus I never zoom in and let's
have a look at the edges here you ready
click hold I'm dragging across it looks
a little bit bad looking better watch
when I let go Oh magic kind of like
brings out this hearing the interaction
starts working so maybe my brushes is it
too big now work along the edges here
and what I might do I find working with
decontaminate colors off in this turn it
off while you're working to get to a
good result okay and then you can kind
of come back you can see I'm just
clicking and dragging and it just starts
working with the background magically
okay now remember we're working with a
black background which is the worst what
you'll probably find is that it will end
up on something like white okay and
look at the [ __ ] when it's on white
I'll show you black because it's like
the hottest one but when it's on white
look at the edge is just coming through
I get excited by this one you should too
if you've ever had
masked here and there's tricks right you
can use you can use special things and
kind of like color range you could do a
channel mask those are candy but no more
channel masks and start using this just
the refine edge of brush tool it's just
magic if it goes too far you can use the
- to kind of put it back in okay - kind
of like actually you don't want that
okay or plus to pull it back out you can
kind of chase here's as well you're like
oh that's a big one I want to kind of
bring that out a little bit cuz I'm
whiskers in here that probably needs
some help
bad magic alright if you're not
impressed and find you and make you to
channel masks anyway there is select
subject mixed with this thing called
select and mask and the one thing so
we've kind of done that general stuff
we've done some little fixing up and
bits let's have a look at one last
little bit see this gap in here I'm
going to go back to black so it's easier
to see and there's a bit in here you can
use this plus and minus often it can be
easier just to use this first option
okay the selection okay and I'm going to
use - and I'm going to use a brush size
is my sweet shortcut
remember it's control option hold those
two keys down on a Mac and then click
your left mouse key a mouse button down
drag left and right up bend down okay
and on a PC you remember it's holding
down the Alt key and clicking and
dragging with the right mouse key this
one actually doesn't have a fuzziness
because it's more of a selection voices
and click it once in there you can see
there click what's in there and kind of
just does big chunks using this first
option then you might go in with your
refine edge brush tool and kind of tidy
things up again that back okay and you
should go around the whole thing
I'm not going to for the moment and when
you finish turn decontaminate colors on
let's have a little look zoom out if you
contaminated colors on and off it's up
to you whether you want that kind of
ghosting around the outside and it
really depends on where it's going it's
going on to a white background or
colored background you're never gonna
see that kind of like fringe ghosting
love it and I might have to go in a
little bit here went maybe a little bit
big on the brush right so before you
leave here though is what to do
output to if you turn decontaminate
colors on you have to output to another
layer okay
that's what a little default to let's
have a little look what happens okay you
in it with this original that was the
thing we first made I'm gonna turn this
top one off this one on there was the
bad one switch this one off in this one
on okay now you could delete this last
one here but it's it looks kind you know
like why have I got the second one the
old version because this top one here
that decontaminate colors if you've
turned it on does some weird stuff right
because you're like oh there's my great
undamaged image okay there it is there
and it's just masked out it's all very
non-destructive unless we turn off this
so we right-click the mask
disable it you're like her it's done
some weird stuff so it kind of spreads
out the edges to help get rid of those
color changes okay to get rid of the
ghosting it kind of fakes it and fudges
it so you really need to keep this kind
of a Ridge '''l layer background or not
use that decontaminate colors alright I
like it the Masters so sweet now
remember I didn't go through at all okay
just to save time you can see along the
top here are some beautiful hair poking
through alright so that's it you get
started with a select subject gives you
a good selection and layer mask you know
if you're not happy with it you can
click on the layer mask okay and go to
select a mask and title it all up
alright before we go let's add them to
our library let's call them pug and drag
in the whole layer in there alright
before we get to the next feature I want
you to open up a file that we were
working with file open and soaping this
one called banner ads let's click open
and one thing that's probably gonna pop
up for you then I'm gonna fix now
actually it's not gonna pop up because
I'm gonna fix it I'm gonna throw in a
bonus trick is this is a font I love it
it's called industry industry even gate
and there's a bunch of cool like
versions of it and it's available from
Adobe fonts but you might not have it
and it might cause problem so I'm gonna
show you that's not the trick the trick
is this I need to now go through an
outline all of the ticks
so that you don't get an error there's a
cool feature that people don't use under
layers you can say I want to filter and
just show me because there's like layers
and outboards and big and Missy and
heavy okay you can say just show me all
the type layers please come on so I'm
gonna double click color and drag my
layers a lot bigger I can say all of you
fellas okay right click them and say
convert shape they're no longer fonts so
they've all disappeared okay but it's
not gonna give you an error and you get
a bonus tip turn it off now comes back
on okay there the words are still there
but they're not like editable text I'm
gonna go through them all you can see up
here there's lots of different ways of
filtering your layers to make them a
little bit easier to work with all right
one before we go I end up playing with
drop shadows there's got a little drop
shadow in there you can say actually
want to show all the layers that have a
fix applied to them okay they have an
effect of drop shadow and you can slick
them all and start fixing your drop
shadows that have gone and added to
everything anyway
now for those go back to kine kind of
turns it all off all this little switch
Tunes are on or off so we've got it open
let's get into the next feature hi there
this fourth feature is something called
the frame tool it's new for Photoshop
it's a way of kind of using a clipping
mask but it has this fun little
structure here and it also means I can
switch these out super quick and easy
whilst retaining this circle mask or
frame has a stroke on it stroke if
you're like me you've got other tricks
to do this you'll probably find this one
will be the one that you use the most
all right let's jump in all right to use
the frame tool there's two ways you can
straight-up grab the frame tool it's
this kind of last one down here okay and
up here you've got two modes rectangle
circle okay I'm going to use an ellipse
circle one and then I'm gonna draw
something flipsie out okay roughly that
sort of shape and you can drag stuff
into it okay so
drag my the cool thing about it is that
it kind of resizes the image to fit
doesn't come in its giant size and you
can start adjusting it by clicking on
the frame ok the frame will allow you to
kind of use the Move tool kind of just
move it around the physical frame and
the thing inside and if you click on
just this other part hang so the image
part of this little group you can work
the image inside of the frame kind of
very in designing right and there are
lots of different ways you can do this
in Photoshop the clipping masks and all
sorts of cool stuff but I guess this
one's cool because it's very clear
there's a frame around the outside and
then that is inside of it okay so you
can create one drag it in or you can put
an image in and do it the other way
let's watch this full drag in our image
and work let's click on the word
skyscraper okay and let's drag in our
image so it's going a size wise I'm just
going to not hold shift it all got used
today partially got used to it hey see
you have it image already in there and
you want to kind of mask it up okay one
of the same kind of rounded thing we can
grab our frame tool and you can just do
just drag it over the top you can see it
masks and you can either put the frame
in first drag an image into it all the
other way around put it in a layer make
sure that the layer is selected and I
find it's always better if it's on top
of all your layer stack seems to work a
little better or more consistently okay
so you've got a square option and your a
circle option other perks you can do is
actually what I want to do is I want to
resize it so I took on the frame part
okay and I'm gonna drag it face a big
nice
okay beautiful in your properties panel
you get to add a stroker on the outside
so now click on it pick a color
pick a size okay and you can put in yeah
put a stroke around the outside if you
need to you can put around the inside
the center or the outside get the same
with this one here what does that 38:36
do the same with this one sixty-eight
man sometimes I can see it but I read it
that wrong all right
other things you can do just out of
interest like this one's really bright
and probably a bit too I want to be kind
of more darkish like I saw at the
beginning there if you click on the
image part not the frame it's really
important because you can do things to
the images still but only if you click
on it okay not have both selected or so
both selected one of them or the other
okay you want the image selected I'm
just gonna add an effect I'm gonna add a
color overlay and I'm gonna make it
black just kind of watch that a little
bit all right so that's the frame tool
it's just another way of kind of masking
or clipping masks it's a nice simple way
to do it very clear a little bit more
like InDesign all right before the next
feature the Pug needs a feature maybe to
bring him in Oh
replacing it okay if you have the image
selected you can actually drag things on
top to switch them out that's a really
good thing it's not on my notes here
should have been okay but won't work if
you've got the whole thing selected you
actually have to have the image part
selected I love them so much and so I'm
gonna switch it out to this one you can
see probably the thing I almost missed
was one of the really big features Kay
is that you can switch them out using
that same mask it's not a mask it's a
frame okay so I'm gonna deselect off it
just to click in the background and I'm
gonna grab pug just rake him in bring my
pug and let's make them bigger no
holding shift
okay and I'm gonna put them in here and
then we'll move on into the confirm I
look at the beautiful masking alright
let's get on to our next and last
amazing feature hi there it's time for
the last feature it's kind of like a
group of features it's at the end
because it's not the sexiest of all the
features but it is probably the most
practical and hopefully the one you walk
away with going man it's gonna save me
loads of time now it's to do with app
boards and using out boards for really
large jobs we've only got a really small
one here but you've got to use your
imagination you've got a social media
digital marketing projects you need
consistency across lots of different
touchpoints a lot of different sizes and
you've used out boards before and you've
found them a little bit tough because
some of the kind of like default states
for them are a little bit weird this
little section here is gonna show you
how to master them so that you go fast
in your professional work ready said go
all right first up board trick is going
to be I want to make a duplicate of this
right so we're gonna click on leader
board the name at the top to select it
and we're gonna use the artboard tool
okay you don't need to switch to it if
you click on the name at the top that's
a handy trick not the one I wanted to
give you though because if you hit plus
right you're like ah you notice that
copying and pasting it across which we
know can be problematic so before you do
that hold down the option key on a Mac
the Alt key on a PC click the little
plus and you get a duplicate come on
grab the name drag it over here it's in
my layer panel here let's call this one
rectangle nice its adjust the size the
width needs to be 1500 and the height in
this case for our head needs to be a
thousand
let's head adjust the sizes easily
that's gonna run into a problem that guy
ends up like hey he was on there but
he's kind of like popped out happens all
the time right you just want like hey
just stay in your outboard cuz you're
doing it right you grab the move tool
and you're like alright pug
and then ventually the pug goes I'm no
longer part of head hardboard I'm just
kind of like wandering the earth not
connected to anything like let's do that
it's undo it all until it's all gone
I'll show you the trick so on leader
board here I click the name you can see
there's my leader board I want to grab
all of these things that are on the
leader board here you go and what you
can do is this is option here this is
the magic one this is what does it say
prevent order nesting it's a it's a long
title just says he will not leave that
out board doesn't matter what you do
click on that they all get this late
little lock icon okay it's a lock
probably not the best kind of
description for it but it says locked it
really it's just means if I click on the
Pug okay by himself he will never leave
he'll just be up there he's masked out I
know but it won't kind of pop off into
the no-man's land of the pasteboard so
now if i duplicate it using clicking the
name holding the option key on a Mac Alt
key on a PC over down now width and
height 1500 by 1000 hasn't ended up over
there it's still kind of off-screen
which is I guess a different problem but
I find that's better
okay so here it is these the park frame
I could just move it in and start
messing around with this thing but he'll
never leave that out board another cool
trick for the upwards is that they can
get really complicated right this is
only a reasonably small banner err job
okay or social media job there's not
many things going on okay not many sizes
but pretty complicated cool little trick
is hold down the command key on a Mac or
the ctrl key on a PC and just click this
little Chevron here this little arrow
and it just goes everybody tidy up ha
awesome you can just open up square and
work on that I find that's just a nice
way of going sure it's just clean
everything up so I know where I'm at or
not bit lost okay you can hold in the
command key down and we'll open them all
as well so control on a PC command on a
Mac will close them all up same key fell
down open them
all up again it gets better what kind of
okay so I've got these four let's say
that let's rename this guy so we know
we've got our four different options we
looked at it earlier move we said
actually only show me the type which
I've turned off okay
there's another option in here it says
kind switch it down to outboard the cool
thing about there is it'll only show you
what if I click on the word rectangle at
the top here now move it across we can
zoom in watch click on the name here
only shows me my layers for rectangle so
I can work on this and gate go into here
and start doing stuff turning stuff off
moving the pug around and then it's I
don't have to do anything but watch this
if I click on the plug up here okay I've
switched the leader board for click on
the image down the bottom it switches to
skyscraper so that is super helpful when
you're working with like really big
documents with lots of different out
boards the trick though is new to turn
off when you're finished because if you
leave it on you'll get to your next
project and all cause problems so turn
it off like all the filtering off that's
an easy way or to go back to kind
alright that's it for our board I'll
pass it back to real life 10 you'll
finish up alright so what next if you
haven't already check out there's an
illustrator version very similar to the
format of this video
ok there'll be a link to it in the
description and if you're ready to take
your Photoshop knowledge kind of further
ok and create stuff like this check out
my photoshop essentials or Photoshop
advance courses at BYO l dot me slash
the future
[Music]
alright that is it from me thanks for
having me here at the Future Academy how
did I good people back to you Matthew I
hope you found these tips and tools
helpful if you want a master Photoshop
and learn from an Adobe certified
instructor check out Daniels courses in
the link in the description below if you
want to learn a different piece of
software or go deeper on another one let
us know by leaving us a comment below
as always don't forget to like comment
and subscribe it helps us out we'll see
you guys next time